qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait pas dans le 4
5 - parce que d'un coup d'un seul on l'a
découvert il ya huit jours que y avait
pas eu de concertation avec les
syndicats y avait pas eu assez de
concertation au sein du ps avait pas eu
mais ils ont fait quoi pendant quatre
cinq mois des bouffes ils ont grand
personnes la bagarre entre eux mais
alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait un texte
de loi ça se prépare
c'est avant que ça arrive aux conseils
des milices que s'est concerté travail
et découvrir au moment de passer au
conseil vise qu'il avait été concertée
avec personne
c'est absolument invraisemblable et
d'ailleurs c'est pas crédible
moi je pense qu'en réalité il ya eu de
la concertation il ya eu des discussions
et qu'ils ont voulu passer outre et
comme manuel valls a dit moi il me faut
des espaces il me faut de la libération
de l'entreprise parce qu'il faut
inverser la courbe du chômage
parce qu'aussi nos lensois des résultats
parce qu'il faut des résultats
donc je passe en force et puis ils
voient qu'il ya des réactions
hollande qui se met en retrait olalala
oh la la qu'est ce qui se passe au point
qu'il faille qui déjeunent ensemble soit
disant pour se rabibocher mais où est-ce
qu'on est le premier ministre à se
rabibocher avec le président sur un
texte aurait dû être travaillé avant sur
un test sur l'avant projet duquel
j'avais dit après tout si ça reste comme
la pourquoi pas pourquoi pas sauf que
maintenant on ne sait plus du tout ce
qui aura dedans
donc on va être une prudence extrême et
on va attendre de voir ce qui met dedans
moi je crains qu'un texte qui était soi
disant fait pour plus de dialogue dans
les entreprises pour une véritable un
véritable assouplissement pour que les
entreprises puissent créer de l'emploi
au bout du bout finissent par plus de
réglementations plus de contrainte parce
qu'on aura écouté tout le monde parce
qu'ils veulent pas de valve parce que
l'unef fait peur parce qu'on veut pas
une manif dans la rue juste à hollande
et discréditer parce que le gouvernement
n'a plus aucun poids parce qu'il ya plus
de majorité à l'assemblée
parce que c'est la fin des temps et que
on a compris que l'année 2007 c'était
une année noire ou blanche comme vous
voulez mais je l'est parce qu'il ya plus
de majorité pour gouverner il ya plus de
gouvernements de lignes de leur a pas de
majorité